Parliament president David sir Sully
will announce the winner of the 2019
Sakharov Prize for freedom of thought
the contenders are Ilham tohti an
imprisoned economist fighting for weaker
rights in China the restorers five
Kenyan students raising awareness about
female genital mutilation and the
Brazilian political activists Mariela
Franco chief raoni and cloud Lisa silver
dos Santos MEP s will take stock of the
work done by jean-claude Juncker during
his five years of the head of the
European Commission Juncker and his team
are expected to be replaced by Ursula
Fonda Lyon and her new Commission on the
1st of December the United Kingdom's
exit from the European Union is on the
plenary agenda Parliament will vote its
position on the --use 2020 budget asking
for more funding for erasmus the fight
against climate change and measures to
tackle youth unemployment mep s will
discuss the consequences of the turkish
military operation in northern syria
against Kurdish LED forces following
Washington's decision to withdraw troops
[Music]